hundreds of classrooms in southern
Nevada still without a permanent teacher
but becoming a licensed teacher for
those already within CCSD will be a
little easier thanks to a new
collaboration with UNLV Victoria Saha
joins us live in studio to explain how
this could make a real difference in
your child's education Victoria Kirsten
we've done several stories on the
teacher's shortage the burnout the pay
but this is a unique program that offers
paraprofessionals already in the
classroom working as a teacher's aide to
get licensed to teach full-time and the
best part is their education is paid for
at UNLV all well they're getting
mentored
our answers are going to end in five or
zero Ariana Hicks loves being in a
classroom one two the 29 year old grew
up in Las Vegas and saw for herself how
some underserved areas were lacking
educational resources I want to be able
to reach more kids to give them what I
had when I was in elementary school
Hicks I started in food services within
the Clark County School District and
then became a paraprofessional for a
special ed class at Lincoln Elementary
me teaching will give those students a
chance to get an education that they
didn't think that they were able to get
like they didn't think that they're good
enough to get one when she thought that
was as far as she can get she found out
about the public education foundation
and their collaboration with UNLV
someone says you know you can get your
degree and we'll pay for it and you're
like really really and the response has
been great says pef's president Kirsten
Seer we've even had some bus drivers
apply so these are people who are
already committed to our kids this year
there are 92 CCSD employees like Hicks
enrolled in the paraprofessional
Pathways project at UNLV which is funded
by NV epic grants we are all about again
diversifying our Workforce and making
sure that we are filling that need
according to ccsd's website there are
more than 900 openings for teachers why
are you wanting to get into it versus
like the others who are trying to get
out of it
um I don't know it's just become a
passion of Mines now I just see the need
for learning
UNLV says if a teaching candidate
finishes their General Ed requirements
most are looking at getting their
teaching license within a year